[موسيقى]
خطوات تسير في الارض اليوم وتقلب التاريخ
لتصل في رحلتها الثامنه على خطى العرب الى
صفحه قريبه بعيده عيد اليحيى تتبع في هذه
الرحله خطى القبائل العربيه واشعارها
واثار الرحاله والعلماء لتحديد الخريطه
الاولى لحجر اليمامه ومراحل توسعها حتى
اصبحت الرياض بامتدادها الذي نعرفه اليوم
[موسيقى]
الجهه الغربيه لجبل طويق المهيب هي جبل
العارض عارض يعترض الشرق والغرب وخلف
جدرانه الشاهقه تتربع حجر اليمامه بسهولها
ووديانها
كما جرت العاده ذهب فريق العربيه الى
الخطوه الاولى للانسان في هذه القصه الى
بوابه حجر اليمامه الى طريق القديه
فاعرضت اليمامه وشمخرت
كاساف بايدي مصلحين خطوه بعد خطوه رسمت
هذه السلسله الوثائقيه خريطه بدايتها وصول
بني حنيفه من الحجاز الى نجد واستقرارهم
في وادي العرض الذي تحول فيما بعد الى ما
يعرف بوادي حنيفه ثم تاسيس الدوله
السعوديه الاولى فالثانيه حتى نشات الدوله
الثالثه
على ضفاف وادي حنيفه العظيم
في المرتفعات جبل العارض ويمتد في مسافه
مئه كيلو متر وصلنا الان الى وادي بوظه
اباط قديما وهو من روافد وادي حنيفه
الاساسي اكيد ان الاعشى يعرف وادي نمار
وربما سلك هذا الوادي عندما ذهب الى
الحجاز
[موسيقى]
لتعويض ما اخفته ايادي الزمن قام عيد
اليحيى ببحث اكاديمي وميداني ثم ذهبت
كاميرات العربيه توثق اوديه حجر اليمامه
وابراجها وسدودها حتى قصر المصمك والدرعيه
ثم ذهبت في خطوات اكبر الى جبال العارض
والابكين حيث تمت محاكاه لحظات من حروب
الرده بخيول عربيه اصيله على صهواتها
فرسان استخدموا سيوفا ودروعا واقواسا خرجت
من متحفها للمره الاولى
مايحت العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات